the movie opens up in the busy Market of
pagoda Colombia there are traffic jams
everywhere and we see random people
selling stuff to make a living outside
the perimeter of Belco Industries armed
guards are thoroughly checking the IDS
and vehicles of the employees the CEO
Barry is astonished that he has asked
for identification as well one of the
employees speaking a native language is
sent home by the armed guards after the
strict checkup all the workers get
inside the building and prepare for work
oblivious to them all the rooms even the
toilet are constantly being monitored
through cameras Danny is a newcomer to
Belco and so she is being briefed about
the new facilities including the Tracer
implanted on the back of her head she is
told that the tracers for her protection
against kidnapping we get to know that
Belco is an international corporation
that hires American workers to work in
South America elsewhere the office's
creep Wendell continuously stares at the
beautiful Leandra and doesn't stop even
when she notices him after a while while
a nerdy guy named Mike approaches her
and the two start making out however
Leandra suddenly stops and exclaims that
she just got through a divorce and
doesn't want to rush things later Mike
enters his co-worker Terry's room and
inquires about why only few people are
present today Terry doesn't know the
actual reason either but he assumes that
the locals didn't show up because they
were sent home by the guards at the gate
a confused mic then heads back to his
room and stares suspiciously at the
hangar next to his building he calls off
his security Evan to inquire about the
strange circumstances but even the
latter has no idea suddenly a mysterious
voice on the intercom alerts everybody
in the building to stop working it says
that there are 80 people in the building
and most of them will be dead within
eight hours if the given task is not
completed the task is to eliminate any
two employees within 30 minutes
otherwise worse consequences will be
faced hearing this everybody starts
panicking and crying in fear their
worries grow even more when they find
out that the telephones are dead and the
cell networks are jammed left with no
options Mike tells everyone to evacuate
the floor calmly but as they are doing
so reinforced metal plates suddenly seal
every door and window from outside now
everyone inside the office starts
realizing that the threat is real as
they are freaking out Mike calmly tells
the maintenance workers bud and Lonnie
to melt the metal with a blowtorch
however even after this the doors are
unaffected some workers rush to the roof
to check if they can alert anyone
outside the premises down in the hall
the COO Barry tries to pacify his team
by explaining that someone might be
playing a prank on them but Mike is
convinced as he thinks the situation may
be serious he suspects that the dead
telephones armed guards and the movement
of guards on the old hangar are all part
of a bigger plot at the roof a woman
notices an armed guard inside the guard
post she hurriedly informs other staff
members and calls them to shout for help
the guard hears them and looks towards
the roof but he completely ignores them
as if nothing has happened the stoner of
the group Marty believes that all of
this is a psychological test so he tells
everyone on the roof to remain calm
however right after he finishes talking
a female worker's head explodes
zoinks then three other workers perish
in the same fashion down in the lobby
the terrified staff assumes that someone
is shooting at their heads so they all
flee to take cover after the explosions
stop Barry gets up and goes to
investigate the corpse after which he
confirms that the wound is not caused by
a bullet Mike also joins him and
confirms that it was the Tracer which is
installed in the back of every
International worker's head realizing
that they are in deep trouble Mike
quickly locks himself inside the toilet
and tries retrieving the Tracer with a
knife but right then the voice on the
intercom interrupts him by threatening
to blow his head off in the next 10
seconds if he doesn't stop hearing this
Mike reluctantly obliges meanwhile after
busting through the objects hung on the
wall the staff member members find that
there are cameras everywhere inside the
building down at the basement where Dany
is hiding bud and Lonnie go to fix the
air conditioner but is having a look at
the AC fans when the voice on the
intercom resumes it says the game is
real and that no one should destroy the
cameras or plug out the tags from their
heads the voice further orders the staff
members to eliminate 30 people among
them in the next two hours otherwise 60
more workers will have to perish with
their heads exploding hearing this
everyone freaks out as soon as the voice
stops Wendell and some co-workers
collect knives from the cafeteria While
others flee to a quiet place to hide in
the basement Bud tries to calm Lonnie
but to his surprise the latter hits him
on the head eliminating him instantly
Lonnie then spots Danny in her hiding
spot and rushes to take her out however
she fights back and manages to kill him
instead by pushing him against a pillar
up in the hall Barry Wendell and Harry
are considering the killing option while
every other person in the room refuses
it so Leandra comes up with an alternate
idea of hanging banners from the rooftop
to set them up Leandra and Mike collect
things like paints rope and duct tape
and head to the elevator while going
upstairs Mike Leandra and Evan intersect
Barry and his group melting the locks of
the Armory scared that they will be
punished Mike requests that they stop
but the bad guys continue torching the
Armory locks enraged Mike pulls out a
gun shoots at the gas tank and then
heads towards the rooftop with his group
in the next scene the stoner Marty
empties every single jar of drinking
water inside the office building
thinking that his fellow co-workers are
hallucinating because of it wait they're
putting LSD in the water scoop back at
the rooftop Mike and a friend are trying
to hang a banner that reads we are being
held hostage however the armed guards on
the ground start shooting at them and
forcing the group to retreat down at the
stairs Mike tells Leandra that he thinks
the whole situation is a human
experiment someone is trying to extort
some sort of information from them just
then Barry arrives there and knocks Mike
out with a Blow To The Head Wendell then
points a knife at Evan and asks for the
keys to the Armory but the latter denies
he instead throws them away and because
of this an angry Wendell stabs him to
death after retrieving the keys Barry
opens up the Armory and distributes
various pistols to his group members the
armed group then forces all the
co-workers back to the lobby later Barry
categorizes everyone into different
groups to weed out workers that can be
eliminated he mostly picks the old and
the diseased ones however the number of
expendable people is still very low
they're running out of time it is only
20 minutes from the deadline left with
no options Barry decides to manually
pick the targets and starts shooting at
their heads Mike is also one of the
targets when Terry is about to fire at
him suddenly Dany pulls off the electric
main switch and everyone including Mike
flees to find cover the voice on the
intercom then announces that only 29
people are dead in just two minutes are
remaining there should be one more
elimination in the next 120 seconds
otherwise 30 more will perish in the
meantime Leandra is being followed by
Terry but she manages to hide under a
table she tricks him with her shoes and
then attacks him from behind injuring
him badly Terry lies down on the floor
pleading for mercy and despite all that
he has done Leandra lets him go soon the
time is up but the workers are one body
short and the task is not completed as a
consequence as previously mentioned the
voice explodes the heads of 31 more
people including Terry the voice on the
intercom tells that the rule of the last
stage is simple the one with the maximum
number of eliminations in the next hour
is allowed to live at this point Barry
has the most eliminations with 11
followed by Wendell with seven Danny and
her friend climb on top of the elevator
to hide but Barry steps inside and dials
for the seventh floor there is a metal
railing just above the seventh floor and
to avoid being crushed Dany jumps off
the elevator top to a side beam
unfortunately her friend cannot make it
on time and as a result he gets crushed
this stops the elevator trapping Barry
inside down in the cafeteria on the
first floor Leandra finds Marty and his
friend chat digging out the unexploded
bombs from the dead people's heads they
are planning to use the bombs to make a
hole through the metal shield so that
they can escape later Leandra reaches
for the intercom microphone and calls
out for Mike asking him to come get her
on the first floor up in the elevator
Barry breaks The Handlebar and
eventually cranks the lift door open
meanwhile as Leander is trying to drink
some water she notices Wendell dragging
and butchering a corpse terrified Marty
and shet Joyner and the three try to
overpower him together unfortunately
despite being injured the Ferocious
Wendell finishes off Chet and Marty and
then goes after Leandra but before he
can kill her as well she cleverly pushes
a table against him and then ends him
with an ax in the next scene Mike and
Leandra find each other in the lobby and
breathe a sigh of relief meanwhile Danny
hangs onto the other side of the
elevator to get out from the floor and
at the same time Barry gets out from the
lift with the help of The Handlebar down
in the basement a man is making a
Molotov cocktail from generator fuel and
some glass bottles Leander shows Mike
the bombs taken out from the deceased
heads which he puts in his pocket
suddenly The Man From The Basement
throws a Molotov cocktail at a woman
burning her alive he also slings it
towards Mike and Leandra but Mrs
bianches just then Barry arrives and
shoots the molotov guy dead he also
manages to injure Leandra at the same
time Dany slips inside the elevator and
heads down to the ground floor but as
soon as the lift door opens Barry
finishes her off with a single shot
leaving only three people Barry Mike and
Lee Andra the couple hides inside a
closet and has a brief chat where Micah
shares her that they will get out of the
place safely however the injured Leandra
doesn't respond and she slowly succumbs
to her injuries now just the two Mana
remaining after a while Barry arrives at
the room following the blood trail and
out of Rage Mike jumps out from the
closet and attacks him this leads to an
intense fight which involves several
punches and kicks however in the end our
protagonist finally manages to Kill the
Bad Guy by continuously hitting him with
a tape dispenser Mike is now the sole
survivor among 80 employees of Belco
Industries and the voice on the intercom
congratulates him the metallic Shields
also retract from the doors and windows
and soon two guards enter the hall and
hold Mike he is taken to the old Hangar
next to the building where he meets The
Man Behind The Voice on the intercom a
confused mic is then dragged to its
share where he is interrogated The Man
reveals that the game is an experiment
performed by social scientists and its
goal is to collect date data for society
modeling in the future to everyone's
surprise Mike has already planted the
tiny bombs onto the guards and at an
opportune moment he rushes to the
Detonator switch and explodes the bombs
of every worker's name except his when
the guards fall down he takes the gun
from one of them shoots other remaining
officers and fires several rounds at the
main man until he runs out of bullets in
the final scene Mike comes out of the
hangar faces the sky with closed eyes
and dropped the gun The View slowly
zooms out to disclose multiple screens
where the workers from other Belco
companies have survived from their
corresponding experiments subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching